des experts affirment qu'il est
impossible de savoir comment a empiré la
prolifération des algues bleu vert dans
les lacs du québec en fait depuis la
baisse marquée des analyses d'eau
effectuées par le ministère de
l'environnement on a parlé avec que
sébastien sauvé les professeurs en
chimie environnementale à l'université
de montréal bonjour monsieur sauver
bonjour d'abord rappelé nous brièvement
le secret c'est algues bleu vert dont on
parle est amplement il ya une dizaine
d'années là d'où vient-elle ou juste
vivre sur terre on est vraiment présent
dans à peu près tous les cours d'eau
donc c'est quelque chose qui est normal
d'avoir un très faible niveau
le problème c'est quand on leur donne
trop d'engrais trottera centre bell et
ont proliféré
c'est le scandale qui parfois mais pas
trop sur les chanter bon il ya quelques
années ont régulièrement ça faisait
l'actualité dans certaines régions ont
fermé des plages à cause d'une quantité
trop importante de cyanobactéries
pourquoi il ya moins d analyse
maintenant il ya eu effectivement au
moment de la crise mais il ya eu
probablement un excès hautement on a un
peu paniqué et donc je pense qu'il veut
un réflexe sain panique et donc à lancer
les informations étaient une bonne idée
par contre par l'effet réponse a été
reporté dans les budgets parce qu'il ya
eu des coupes drastiques budgétaire au
provincial et j'ai aussi trouvé son
travail avant de façon d'éviter que ce
soit dans l'un l'une des méthodes pour
faire d'un ali el anka rien à la partie
algérienne a rapporté mais ça c'est que
oui on ne sait pas on affole plus
affoler la population il ya plus de
panique mais il n'y a pas d'information
en présence n'ont aucune idée
quels sont les corps effectivement il y
aurait du plomb d'agde qui peuvent être
créés dans quel camp il ya des blooms
d'agde qui sont pas toxiques matin quand
je dis petit blues
on arrête creek dont toutes ces réponses
là bas les gens qui décident et ses
thématiques mans sb les plus plein de
lots oublie pas ce sera exactement c'est
pas lui parlons-en des risques à quel
point un peu dangereuse cette bactérie
dans les filets les produits donc les
problèmes associés à sa délégation
cutanées des diarrhées des problèmes
gastro intestinaux
donc ce qui est le plus 30 à nyon le
plus rapide le plus fréquemment
rapportés mais les fans aux toxines sont
liés à des problèmes d'intoxication au
niveau des reins au niveau du foie il ya
des neurotoxines très affecté tous sont
des choses qui sont dans certaines de
cette controversée à la ix20
reproduction l'écho les plus médiatisés
ces points lui seul il est pas les chats
les chiens qui vont aller dans les
cordes au manger du lag sur un fond de
l'eau et qu'ils vont être effectués
donc si je comprends la pour résumer
c'est que le ministère a arrêté de faire
donc des analyses pour pas trop nous
rire les médias on pourrait dire c'est
ce que fait ce que j'en comprends mais
en bout de ligne
est-ce que selon vous le citoyen est
suffisamment informés aujourd'hui sur la
présence de ces algues dans certains cas
le transfert dans la citoyenneté brin de
la dre y auraient droit à voir c'est
quoi les fondus de provins qui est en
soi la caisse que ce jeu médailles sont
sans problème
ou est-ce que d'associer nos bactéries
qui produit de cette taxe mais il ya un
certain nombre de problèmes de santé
humaine important est ce qu'il faut
éviter de voir loïc on peut quand même
se baigner occasionnellement
oui il faut absolument éviter tous les
contacts les kayaks et c'est historique
sur une problématique vertement son lac
ne sort pas trop comment réagir
alors que quelques années on pouvait le
l'informer de façon régulière et bien
merci beaucoup monsieur sauver ces
bassins sauver donc je ne rappelle cette
professeure en chimie environnementale à
l'université de montréal merci beaucoup
on peut pleurer